and the last uh part of the problem we
figured out that the function of
of the height of the ferrous wheel the
people of the ferris wheel at any time
is a function of t h of t
is equal to 9 minus 8
cosine
of 18
t
where t is in seconds now the second
part of this problem they want us to
graph h as a function of t between
t
z oh sorry between zero is less than or
equal to t is less than or equal to 30.
so let me
draw
axes
so let's say that
that's my h axis
and let's say that this is my t-axis
this is h
and this is t
and so this is t equals 0 and this is t
is equal to 30 seconds
30 seconds
i get confused when i see this 18 here
whatever so what i'm going to do first
of all is i'm going to graph a different
function slightly different function
then i'll translate it to this function
i'm going to graph h of theta
is equal to 9
minus
cosine
sorry 9 minus 8 cosine of theta
i think you'll see where i'm going with
this when i'm all done so let's try to
graph h of theta is equal to 9 minus 8
cosine of theta
so when t is equal to 30 seconds what is
theta equal to so 30
30 times 18 that's 540. so this is 540
degrees same thing i'll write the thetas
in red above the t axis this is 540
degrees so that's like two times around
the circle so that's 540 degrees
then this is going to be roughly
270 degrees
and so
90 degrees would be about a third of
this so that would be 90 degrees
that'd be 180 so that'd be 90 degrees
that'd be 180 degrees
this would be
360 degrees
and then this would be 360 plus nice
would be 450 degrees
and if you wanted to figure out the
corresponding time you just take this
degree and divide by 18. so it's 90
divided by 18 is what it's uh
it's 5 right 5 times yeah so this is so
if i were to write here this is at 5
seconds
5 seconds this is at 10 seconds this is
15 seconds
this is 20 seconds
this is
sorry this is 25 seconds and this is 30
seconds right and actually a simple
thing we could do is uh let's just do it
let's just figure out what the value of
the function is at these points
because these are pretty easy
degrees to figure out what the cosine
value is
so let's figure out
let me draw a table
let me tables are always good and i'll
do it in yellow
so i'll draw t
t
theta and h
this might be a kind of unconventional
way of doing things but i have a simple
mind so this is actually how i like to
do it
so i like to think of theta as 0
and 540
450 and t the corresponding time of
those is
20 25 30. and you could you know this is
it's not rocket science here when t
equals 15 seconds 15 times 18 we're
trying to find the cosine of 270 degrees
right 15 times 18 is 270 degrees i'm
just doing this because i don't have a
calculator and this will help me pick
good points so when t is equal 0 what is
height
well or t is equal zero theta is equal
to zero so cosine of theta
is cosine of zero is one so nine minus
eight it's one
let me do h in a different color so this
is one
cosine of 90 degrees cosine of 90
degrees is 0. so 9 minus 0 is 9.
cosine of 180 degrees we're going all
the way around the unit circle so cosine
180 degrees is -1
so -1 times minus 8 is plus 8. so 9 plus
8 that's 15.
cosine of 270 degrees we're pointing
straight down so the x coordinate is
going to be 0. so once again
we're at 9 again
all right nine minus zero
360 degrees cosine of 360 degrees is the
same thing as cosine of zero right
so once again it i mean we've gone
around the circle once right
so it's going to be same as zero so it's
going to be 1
and 450 is going to be the same thing as
90. so it's going to be 9
and then 15 degrees
so let's plot these points
h of so actually let me just draw 15 up
here so this is so what are the points
that keep showing up so if this is one
that's one
uh
that's one and then let's see then we
have nine
one there's two three four five six 7 8
10 11 12 13 14 15
15.
all right fair enough
okay so if we got let me draw some
guidelines just to help us
this is a little bit
so i'm gonna i'll draw actually let me
do them kind of
hard to see
just because i don't wanna
draw too much attention to the
guidelines
so i can do one guideline like
there
then i'll do a bottom guideline
right there
bottom guideline right there and then
the 9 keeps showing up
9. oh you know what i can't add what's 9
what's 9 plus 8 it's not 15. it's 17.
sorry i i can't i just i don't know why
i'm
all right when
clearly i need to practice my addition
so this is 9 plus 8 this is 17 and i
realized that just because i was like
well 9 should be in the middle so this
is actually 17. ignore my little marks
here
that's 17 this is 1.
and just ignore the marks 9 would be
right in the middle between
1 and 17.
so let me draw kind of that median point
right there
so this is it 9. sorry i can't add
properly
and then let's draw the graph let's or
at least plot the points on the graph
so zero at t equals zero we're at h
equals one so that's this point
that's right here
when t equals 5 h is equal to 9
it's right here
when t is equal to 10 h is equal to 17
h is
17.
when t is equal to 15
h is 9 again since it's right here
at 20 we're back at 1.
i think you see the pattern at 25 we're
back at 9.
and then at 30 we're back at 17 not 15
because now i've
corrected my mistake and this is going
to be a sign graph so it's going to look
something like this
it's kind of like let me do a vibrant
color so i can kind of override
everything that's going to look like
something like this it's going to go
whoops and then up and then down here
oh whoops my thing just disappeared so
it's going to go up like this
curve up
come back down and curve
up
and then come back down like that so
that's our graph so if we i think in in
the problem they tell us to approximate
actually let me open up my
cousin's
problem
my
other account is
timed out on me while i recorded this
they wanted to approximate when
when t equals four what the height is so
when t equals four the height is like i
don't know it's like right around there
right
so the height is a little bit less than
nine and so it's i don't know seven or
eight meters in the air
and when time is equal to ten well time
equals 10 we figure out exactly we know
that they're 17 meters
in the air so i know this was kind of a
little messy and graphing trig functions
tend to be
but hopefully you found this vaguely
useful
have fun